[Music]
occasionally people will mistake me for
somebody else
and i was at the apple store recently we
both were this was during covid so we
were wearing masks and
the security guard said oh you know we
were talking about how long it would
take and
the security guard came up to us and
said i wish i could get you to the head
of the line because i'm a big fan and i
was like oh thank you and he said yeah
i've seen all your movies and um and he
started listing movies that i wasn't in
500 days of summer oh yeah i said oh you
maybe you mean this other one he goes no
very funny i know you were in 500 days
of summer and inception
all these like really good movies
he thought i was joseph gordon-levitt
and i said no and he but he thought i
was like trying to keep a low profile he
goes ah okay don't worry you're like
you're secret's safe with me and i was
like i'm not but and it's ironic that
this happened at the apple store of all
places
you're listening to life is short i am
your host joseph gordon uh justin long
life could be a dream sweetheart
[Music]
with me as always is my brother
christian gordon-levitt don't get people
excited
yeah the last time i saw joe was in uh
new york he was with a bunch of have i
told you this oh the clowns yeah he was
uh it was in it was on one of those
little shops on ludlow
joe was with a bunch of um yeah russian
clowns
who who aren't they're romanian clowns
oh maybe or are you conflating that with
the seinfeld episode where
romanian gymnast i don't know but he's
such an interesting guy
and um
that's just a one little
example of why he's so interesting he's
like you know he's into so many
different creative things and and i know
he was at that point he was going
through a
either a russian or a romanian clown
face
and i was like he was like this is
sergey and this is i and they were like
hitler and they were these he was into
it he was like immersed doing an
immersion thing he is very interesting
he's also very handsome i would say oh
that's the main reason so uh your eyes
even if even though you're wearing a
mask just your eyes being recognized as
his eyes i think it's a pretty
flattering thing oh very oftentimes
that's a rare occasion when it's like
i'm mistaken for somebody and it's
flattering
and this happened to you too i know
where lately since you've been on
instagram and we've been doing the show
occasionally people will be like tag
their friend and they're like oh how
much you look exactly like this guy
invariably i'll i'll click on the person
and be like really they think i look
like him i think i might have a slightly
higher opinion of my own face than that
is objectively i think i i guess i do
too because often times except for the
joseph gordon 11 moments i
it's i'm not flattered by it it's like
somebody who um
it's also often and this is not the
unflattering part it's often somebody
who is
of latin descent
uh or or eight southeast asians for you
yeah
yeah well you definitely have an asian
flair uh-huh i've gotten
i mostly get um either you or david
schwimmer and i think
both of those are pretty flattering oh
thanks i i've gotten david trimmer i've
got david schumer's a little more
flattering but of the friends he was
like the the
dorky one right yes um i the most
flattering for me is the occasionally
keanu reeves that always makes me happy
doesn't beat that yeah god that's person
goals anyway you know who else you look
like who our guest today oh
yes that's right that's okay so that's
why we're talking about it we've been
mistaken for one another in fact she is
100 your celebrity doppelganger i would
say our guest today is carrie brownstein
from the groundbreaking two
groundbreaking things uh slater kinney
the band and um the incredible show
portlandia i did the show on imdb
podcast and i depict three movies that
that um
meant the most to me and like i i wanted
to talk about and i think if it was a tv
version of that portland you would be on
it be portlandia seinfeld maybe simpsons
yeah wow how about high praise oh it's
the bet three favorites well now i feel
bad not oh
but i don't know if i'd put in my top
three top three is tough to correct okay
well um i mean you got alf charles in
charge and empty nest that's how do you
crack those twists that is true
that's true and uh designing women yes
um by the way i saw designing women in
maggie's queue
that she watched maggie q no
in maggie's
queue
yeah not in maggie q it's an important
distinction it's important yes it was
weird you saw an x-ray of her and
you saw she just swallowed a dvd
strange
um
you know if maggie q heard that joke
she'd be like she'd laugh and then she
go
so stupid
i can hear um anyway i love the show and
we'll talk you know if you love it too
or if you're not familiar with it even i
still think it's interesting to talk
about um
and i just was so honored to be on it
and talk about all that so you look like
her you look very much like her yeah
that led to you being on the show here's
how uh well here's how it happened i was
i would always get people on twitter
when i first got on twitter people would
tweet that a lot to both of us and um
we'd occasionally run into one another
carrie and i wouldn't and we'd always
bring that that would always come up
like oh i got another message you know
and and she's like well you got to come
on the show we should and i said i love
the show she knew i loved the show so um
eventually they wrote a part for
somebody who looks like carrie's
character lance carrying fred armstrong
his character lance and nina like a
gender reversal yeah but extreme
versions of the gender and um
carries lance is like sort of tough uh
works on motorcycles and is you know
doesn't want to like be emotional around
nina and and friends like nina's like oh
just want to get married and you know
it's just like these extremes of um
traditional gender norms i played
lance's uh step soon to be stepfather i
start dating lance's mom
uh who incidentally i don't think we
talk about this uh was supposed to be
cher
when i when i uh found out i was doing
it they were like oh and and cher's
gonna be your lover um playing lance's
mom uh that didn't happen but it was a
great actress uh all the same and it was
one of those fun jobs i've ever done
let's get into it okay thanks for that
context that was really are you being
sarcastic no oh okay i'm not always
sarcastic i know but when you compliment
i i also felt like it was rambling a
little bit no i thought it was it okay
good you hit all the points oh cool okay
i'll take that um and for people who
already knew that information i'm sorry
that you hear it again but i think it uh
that context is sort of important okay
good um so now uh the most important
part of this show my catch up with my
doppelganger my bizzaro
and my friend carrie brownstein
life could be a dream
hello hello again so we'll meet again
[Music]
god you know carrie that your song um
can uh everyone i know is why
it's been uh my brother and i directed
our this our first movie we're really
excited about it and we're uh
we we have used that song
i i hope i think we can get it we're
talking to your uh late whoever i think
we already approved it oh no [ __ ]
this is the official oh this is contract
this is contractual are you recording
i'm recording it's yeah oh yes i i was
beating around the bush i didn't know
how to say
have you heard anything oh my god we
love it's like okay great
no it's legally binding oh man
um i can't wait to show it to you uh no
i'm excited that's by the way
congratulations that's a big thing big
deal carrie yeah we're so happy with it
and
i don't know if you know there's melanie
linsky and judy greer but they're
they just give the most
incredible you know i know both of them
briefly well judy we had on portlandia
and
i adore her
and melanie i think i have met very
briefly and i'm just a huge fan of hers
i mean i'm a big fan of both of those
actors yeah you you will be even more so
i think uh
oh that's great okay well um i'll talk
to you later
okay i'm glad we're okay deals just this
is about deals is this podcast called
deals
um what wait but you you were in austin
then
or l.a no i i was in l.a i know we we
have mutual friends
in austin and i i have thought of living
there but i've never i lived there once
for a very
short amount of time i wouldn't even i
hesitate to use the term well
unfortunately i think you maybe told me
that like around the time that we were
hanging out more and around i was like
oh i live in austin
or i'm an unreal unreliable narrator
right off the bat wow okay
um so okay i'm jeez well so we got the
song you're not living in austin
um where are you where are you you're in
the berkshires you're in i'm actually in
connecticut now we have a little like um
we have this compound studio room in uh
not far from where i grew up in
connecticut but i've been spending a lot
of time in massachusetts in the
berkshires yeah
um
and i i just got an rv there's this rv
company
uh called boho
uh and i and i just
decided to have them make me an rv so
i'm i'm excited actually to drive out to
uh your neck of the woods and
i just miss traveling i miss
being out you seem like a wanderlust
type person
yes and no
i
definitely i think touring from such a
young age
i mean
young i mean 19 or 20. i don't mean like
from the age of five but uh like a von
trapp yeah no not not in a family band
but i think it it really instilled this
sense of nomadicism in me and i do get
restless so i'm in one place for a while
but when i'm gone when i'm traveling i
miss being home so i sort of need the
mix of it very similar yeah but now are
you are you i know you're creating now
you're being creative or attempting to
do you feel that restlessness now while
you're working
i don't
i think because at the beginning of the
pandemic
my band had just gotten home from tour
so we we came back from europe
like on march 2nd we were probably one
of the last
bands to complete like a full tour
definitely in europe but probably in the
us everything all bands stopped touring
like a couple weeks later yeah and so i
was ready to be home and then i thought
once travel was restricted that i would
be um
restless but after a while i just wasn't
but i did have to sort of reconfigure
my mindset to to just being home and i
started walking a lot more i i've always
been
um someone who takes hikes and walks as
a way of thinking and a way of like
processing
what i'm working on just to kind of get
that input
and feel porous but uh i really started
walking many miles like kind of turning
into one of those sort of like urban
hikers where you just set out because
there's nothing there was no traffic so
i was just
wow yeah yeah um
like with a stick with like uh
not with a stick okay
that's like portlandia's sketch
territory no i know yeah i i always try
to avoid that here as i can i feel
conspicuous if i'm embodying something
but by the way all those characters were
based on iterations of myself anyway so
i'm always a little i'm always a little
bit embodying those but no it was just
that
there's no just remember how there's at
the beginning there was kind of no
destinations because there was nothing
open it wasn't like i'm gonna walk and
get coffee or yeah you know so
you just start realizing i guess i can
cross the bridge and go downtown and
then i can you know it just there was
sort of no boundaries for a while and
and also psychologically which made it
also very torturous yeah i hate saying
anything you know remotely positive
about this time warren but it's i
noticed that i mean that is a positive
byproduct that i noticed too even here
where i live which is um
which is an upper scale
suburban i remember my parents when when
i was a kid because my dad was a teacher
my mom was an actress and we didn't grow
up with a lot of money so they would
always
they would always call everyone yuppies
you know like
so it's an area where there were a lot
of there was a lot of affluence and
stuff
but even here i've noticed a lot of
people uh so many more than i ever
remember just walking and families
outside and
looking at fireflies in the sun
there's something kind of nice about a
return to
nature even in this suburban place where
i live
i was kind of charmed actually seeing
people because you know when you i've
lived in this neighborhood for a long
time so you sort of know who the
the walkers are who the runners are who
the you know skateboarders are but there
was such an influx and there were
definitely people where i was like
you've never taken a walk here before or
like this is your first time this is
your first time jogging and it was
really it was but i felt very
encouraging of all the new runners
because i'm i'm a very terrible runner
i'm not good at it so i was like and
even just the people kind of walking for
the first time like people that usually
just like drove to work then drove to
the gym
and now we're like i am walking
yeah yeah well i've noticed
i've driven i just realized when people
had stopped driving and the gym was
closed i realized
the gym was like a four-minute walk from
where i lived but i'd get in my car
and i drive there which is ludicrous
it's it defeats kind of defeats the
purpose uh
i do what do you mean that you're a bad
runner does that mean like you look
funny doing it you you don't have good
feelings oh i know i look amazing doing
it but i just
uh
you've never seen a gazelle like me in
in track shoes but
um
no i mean that
i don't always have the mental fortitude
for it and i i get bored and all the
things that sort of uh limit
you as a runner i think you kind of have
like meditation it's something where
you just get better at it and it feels
pain or like anything really but it kind
of takes that
this this discipline not just physically
but mentally that i sometimes just peace
out on really early me too shutting your
mind it's hard for me to shut my brain
down and i i'm sure i know meditation
would be a very positive thing in my
life i've
it's embarrassing how many people have
recommended it to me
[Laughter]
and i'll try it i'll be oh you know i'll
give this in five minutes in the
thoughts are going and i feel like i'm
not accomplishing anything it's uh
i get restless i guess pretty easily um
yeah me too i used headspace for a while
which is kind of a great app actually
and they they really
um break it down into
small very achievable
goals okay so add me to the list of
people recommending invitation to you as
someone ask someone who doesn't meditate
those are the best those are the best
people to give you advice
all right yeah yeah you um what are you
what are you writing now are you is
there music that you're writing or are
you writing i have i have been writing
music i've been finishing a script and
um
so that's been the majority of
this summer and it started really slowly
i just
there was
i don't
early on
the pandemic started i think there was
this like false remember that whole
thing that was circulating like
shakespeare finished i can't remember
what it was like king lear or something
during you know the bubonic plague or
whatever it was like it was as if and i
do think now that people have kind of
you know dug themselves out of
despair or are finding ways of dealing
with like the multitudes of despair that
is going on i do think that there will
be some interesting art and
creative um output from this time but
early on i just i found it completely
debilitating to kind of sit in the
uncertainty and so i got kind of a slow
start you know what i was like i'm going
to knock this out i mean by april 1st
i'll be done with this and probably
writing you know a novel that just
didn't happen so it's it's like
shakespeare
just yes all of us are shakespeare
it's what was but was it a an idea that
had been percolating and and you've just
been sitting on it no this is like this
is a full this is an assignment i mean
this is something i signed on to do and
that's actually
been hard too because i don't that's not
usually the world that i work in and it
was a
i don't know how much i can speak to it
but basically
i was excited about this idea it
involved a lot of research i wanted to
take it on
i love the producer
you know it was already set up somewhere
studio wise like it just oh wow and and
so i i went for it and
it yeah it was hard because it's just
not a world
i'm used to working in in terms of
you know
like researching it's it involves it's
based on real people
so yeah it's been a learning experience
for sure and and this would probably be
this around the time that you guys uh
your time now would
used to have been occupied by portlandia
writing right i mean it was it was just
like i remember it was like the four or
five of you that would
write all of yes
yeah towards the end more like
i think we had maybe seven or eight
writers maybe seven which is still
pretty small
uh yeah so that ended i think two
summers ago and then the last few
summers i was
either directing
or
i guess last summer i was getting ready
to go out on tour with slater kinney so
two things which i
have been a really nice um
substitute for portlandia and i won't
even call them substitutes because it's
some of them existed before portlandia
but yeah no this has
been the mellowest summer in terms of uh
i guess i bet well there's also that i
just remember you you're reminding me of
that the the early part of the lockdown
and and that i i do remember that how
people were like
um this is you know this is the time to
be productive doesn't mean we can't be
productive creatively and
uh i i remember struggling with the idea
of there being a future
uh
where where entertainment would still be
worthwhile and it everything seems so
dire and kind of like day to day that
i i remember thinking well it's it's
plus we were finishing up this edit but
and even that seemed like what are we
doing like this the world is falling
apart and we're making this like fart
comedy and and i would go back and forth
between that and like well
people need to laugh and it's gonna be
good for the world um
but i i i think a lot of people maybe
were
a lot of friends of mine were wrestling
with that and have and
and have not really been able to
you know process this
time creatively um
so i'm glad you are
well yeah with
i i guess with caveats because i felt
the same
sense of futility
are you drinking a waterloo i could
i could match your watermelon or sorry
grapefruit waterloo with my own
grapefruit waterloo oh really you should
do that do you have it i'll go
downstairs and get it yeah
because our our last picture
i mean we're almost even in a similar
outfit like i could just pull my hair
back
we can hold up the waterloo
and just claim claim the siblinghood
that people really want for us actually
they just want us to be the same person
yeah you know what's annoying is i still
occasionally on on social media or
you know i'll hear from somebody and
they're like you and carrie brownstein
like yeah we did a whole thing yeah the
whole thing it's it's
we we took it to its like ultimate
conclusion
the most absurd conclusion but you know
yeah i i left twitter and i'm barely on
instagram but yes when i was still on
twitter for sure people love yeah the
comparisons which i mean i still find
charming very totally fine with all yeah
i am too very flattered by it but i i um
and also it led to such a fun
creative thing getting to do that show
which you know i'm such a huge fan of um
that show was just so fun to do and i
bet i i bet you miss it i mean you must
miss it you must miss that outlet
i do miss it i miss the absurdist lens
through which to process yeah phenomena
and yeah just the world you know and i
think
now more than ever
or i mean i think it functioned in the
same way then but
you know sometimes things feel so
outrageous
that
absurdity or surrealism are kind of the
only ways to make sense of it because
coming at it straight on is impossible
because it's yeah it feels like such a
bizarro world especially
with tr with you know trump and
everything so yeah i missed that a
little bit um and just and just kind of
dissecting the minutia of
of things uh was fun but i you know
eight years is a good run and it was
nice
it was nice to sort of just
leave it before
well people still liked it you know yeah
yeah yeah it was still so good and and
but yeah i know what you mean there must
be moments now you stop short of saying
now especially but
because this is there is so much going
on it um
socially and culturally that uh
there are times when i think i i mean i
had i had nothing to do with the show
there are times when i think
god this would just if you if you leaned
into this just a little bit it would be
portlandia sketch i mean
the absurdities of
yeah i think people do that with snl too
when there's some like political moment
going on and snl isn't on the air people
think oh i wish you know you sort of
people view
you know politics or view culture
sometimes through
television especially you know whether
it was i remember when uh the colbert
went off the air as john stewart
people sort of missed that
you know for sure mediation and i think
people miss it uh on snl when you know
there's a a great hearing in the set or
you know they're like oh i wish we had
snl for this yeah if there's some
political character in the theater of
the political theater that's but but
like
portland was so played so real i mean
that was the great
one of the many things about it that
that i think will last for so long it
was played so real and um
so many of the things that it skewered
were uh
it was done in such a subtle way that
you didn't have to like you just leaned
into it just a little bit and you just
it was perfect satire uh
yeah i i'm thinking that's why i i even
had a paranoia about asking you to do
this like i i think i even texted you
like this feels like a
a friend friends who one of whom feels
obligated to do a
the other friends podcast and everyone
has podcasts now and
i just thought oh my god it feels it
reminded me of a portlandia thing that
like
you were constantly you and fred were
constantly getting asked to do podcasts
or something
right
yeah i know what you're saying i think
there was uh
the way we kind of dissected those very
small kind of human
like blunders or interactions did become
i mean for a while you know portlandia
was sort of this adjective that people
used when they were trying to describe
something that was
awkward or sort of something that
started grounded and
all of a sudden felt very you know
insane which almost any interaction can
be like you're saying these are like you
know
the asking to be on podcast i feel
guilty when i ask people for
anything too but i was happy to do that
okay all right good
but i it was in the in the context of uh
portlandia and and
the the
shining a a light on the absurdity of
these moments i it made such perfect
sense i didn't know this about you that
you were a sociolinguist you were a
sociolinguist major yes i was
uh
wait tell people because this is
something we just heard about my brother
uh my brother and i at the end of the
show we kind of dissect
the conversation and and then we read a
letter from somebody and somebody in one
of their letters said to christian
in a complimentary way uh you would be a
great sociolinguist and i we have
neither of us had heard the term
um
yeah i had not heard the term until i
went to college i mean i've i'd
obviously heard of linguistics and
you know there's many branches of
linguistics psycho linguistics and um
sociolinguistics
and i had this professor there susan
fixdall who
was a sociolinguist and
uh it it really just
it was kind of everything that i already
was curious about
in the world and wanted to explore you
know it was just that intersection of
society and language it was how people
talk it was conversational uh
conversation analysis discourse analysis
as it's called so there's all these
offshoots like social linguistics
encompasses like um
you know animal language and child
language acquisition and but the part
that i loved was discourse analysis and
really looking into ways
that people communicate with one another
and
i just
i find it fascinating to this day and i
yeah so yeah and and i think that that
served me well with portland because so
much of what we were doing
on that show totally was
just the analysis analysis and
observational like sort of you know
humor of
like
yeah just the ways people also sort of
perform and enact like personhood with
each other totally um and
because it was fred and ice we were
often
permutations of of different couples it
was like how do people perform
couplehood and the ways that you know a
pair of people sort of move through the
world with
a singular identity and how that
identity is always uh in flux and at
stake was always really interesting to
us so we often built characters out of
like these couplings
yeah that's interesting yeah and the
couples were obviously some of them were
broader than others like
nina and lance who of course you had a
lot of interactions with but as the
years went on actually
that character those characters started
kind of broad but we we by the time you
were on the show
there was a real i think um empathy
towards like we found so much more
compassion and empathy
towards the characters yeah the longer
we embody them because with sketch often
you know you're always sometimes it's
broad strokes but because we got to do
that show for eight years and it became
more character-based because we knew
well this is what people go back to
other tv shows for they go back for the
characters
yeah
we started to you know kind of infuse
them with with a lot more um i don't i
think nuance than you often get when you
just do sketch yeah more humanity yeah i
i i'm now thinking about like it was the
pull out king like for example the pull
out king was that that was like an
earlier yes it was like a that felt more
is that kind of what you're talking
about whereas later then you explored
they relate like the dynamics of their
relationship and when they the episode i
did where they get married and there's
something very touching about i mean
it's like it's ludicrous because fred
and
you know that i i i just didn't know how
you kept a straight face so you guys
were so good about not
breaking but it was i mean i
there were some of those early episodes
especially because we were shooting so
quickly and didn't always have time to
get
coverage or to do other takes the only
available footage of me is just laughing
you know
life could be a dream sweetheart
[Music]
in the early 2000s millions of
households across the world tuned in to
watch contestants battle for the last
rose or to be the final survivor on the
island reality tv was beginning to
dominate the airwaves and every show
needed to be bigger flashier more
scandalous than the last but in the case
of one infamous dating show the real
drama was happening off-screen and it
would shape the future of reality tv the
reality tv series there's something
about miriam seemed like a pretty
standard dating competition six young
men vibed for the affection of miriam
rivera a beautiful model from mexico but
when miriam revealed that she was a
trans woman during the show's finale the
on-screen drama sparked an international
uproar about gender sexuality and
whether reality television had finally
gone too far follow harsh reality the
story of miriam rivera on apple podcast
amazon music or you can listen early and
add free by joining wondering plus in
apple podcasts or the wondery app
[Music]
[Music]
i mean i tried not to break but there
was so much improvisation that you know
if there's a funny joke in a script you
kind of get used to it but you know
right if fred or one of the other actors
just improvises something that i've
never heard before and is completely
hilarious and ridiculous then i can't
help it it was really hard i remember
when um
we were doing that stuff with the i had
the camera and we
did that scene and then and friends just
started going
he started calling me like a sh he goes
you're such a shutterbug he started
calling me a shutterbug and i
he found these
words that were i hadn't heard anyone
use in so long like something like that
like a
shutterbug
it was so hard for me it was really hard
to not laugh but i um
i remember like kind of biting my my
tongue but i'm sure if i were on it
regularly i
i wouldn't have that discipline first to
address that yes fred is really great as
we're you know where some comedians kind
of
go to
a place that's like raunchier to be
funny like yeah fred always finds it in
the sort of innocence of language
and it's it is
disorienting to have someone use the
word shutterbug like
as if it's a put down you know like it's
just
the meanest thing
and it's there's something so
weird and contradictory about
you know being made fun of using this
term that's just like kind of charming
and like colloquial
right right and then
looking at him and he is
in that like wig and the bob and and he
he that's the thing he's so committed it
it's i think part of what made that so
difficult to get through was um
he looks
absurd i mean he looks ridiculous but he
is so committed to being that
woman that it's like um
it's uh which is what made which is what
allowed i guess you guys to explore some
deeper things with those characters and
and you're both so you're both so
committed um
i just loved being around it was just so
fun to to watch because i was such fans
of those characters specifically too
that it was cool to just see you guys
uh
doing it
it was fun i loved i loved when you were
doing the show i still have some of my
favorite photos are just outtakes of us
like
sitting around looking pretty identical
and i was surprised yeah and that voice
and getting to do that and uh
i they don't lower it they did i was
surprised to learn that you guys would
lower it just a little bit oh yes for
sure i think early on they really
pitched it down like for the
cacao the cacao sketch is really pitch
down i think they sort of
well i sort of then ended up kind of
emulating
the pitch down that they had done and so
then i think they could split the
difference oh yeah yeah and fred doesn't
right he just
his was like that he just did a natural
and were those characters uh based on
specific people you said that they're
versions of yourselves um
but but are there are there characters
that you were doing that were that you
could actually point to and say this is
nancy and ryan
right we did have some of that like i
said a lot of them were
like if we had taken specific
chapters in our lives or like a moment
in our life where we did something that
felt
not even extreme but just
you sort of have to pause me like is
that is that me i just
that was such a weird moment we would we
would sort of make a character like if
that was only that like kath
who's
had the ponytail like she's just always
at 10 you know i
any time i ever like just
i don't know i kath now is probably like
yes i was just going to say she's kind
of a karen you know i mean where it's
just that
like very that white
female entitlement and just
um
yeah i mean she she is
a true karen although it in you know in
our show she was normally you know
usually just kind of going after
anyone but
yes so annoying uh
but i see that and it's like that's a
self-critique you know that's that's me
like
not you know
not ever with cruelty but like
you know someone's
on a plane or something and you're just
like
someone with a cat behind me on a plane
and i'm like excuse me you know uh your
cat is you know it's just whenever it's
whenever you get that tone and you're
like god what is that tone i could just
i could just ask the woman with the cat
behind me i could say hey you know like
i can feel the cat under my seat but
instead it's just like you're like why
did i start at 10.
why am i starting here
right and and like not you're not even
being direct i found myself doing that
my my brother's girlfriend margaret
we've been in quarantine together and uh
there's certain things not many things
get under my skin but certain things too
and one of which is uh she leaves the
vents on in the bathroom
so like it's such a dumb silly thing but
like
so instead of just saying hey maggie
could you just turn the vents off when
you like i was like hey um
yeah i noticed that the vents after you
leave are still on it was like what are
you trying to say then you have to like
translate what the other person's saying
which is probably where a sociolinguist
would have fun interpreting how that
person is asking for something um
yeah so so much hedging and it's very
passive-aggressive
yeah anyway i guess to answer your
question so there were some that were
versions of us and then we took a lot of
our parents friends and
uh
also
our own friends yeah so nina and lance
i'm not sure who specifically
they were based on but we
i think for me playing lance i was just
drawing from my own sort of like
heightened versions of
and probably broken versions of
masculinity
and then uh and i'm not sure about fred
but yeah it was it was often you know we
would just you know think of our most
sort of beloved friends and just try to
explore them through
through humor
when you were a kid did you have
aspirations of doing something like that
i i i know
you you do so many different things but
what was the thing when you were growing
up that you thought
oh this is what my future's gonna be
like um or or was there ever there that
moment you know i definitely was an
a performer as a kid probably to the
detriment of myself and everyone in my
family like i was someone who really
like
was constantly putting on
plays with
the neighborhood kids and oh really just
really like
hey guys i know it's summer but if we
could just meet at 10 a.m
you know on
on peter's deck we're going to have a
rehearsal
you know like
for lanford wilson's fifth of july yes
so bossy and just always trying to get
everyone else everyone else just wanted
a summer people wanted to
ride their dirt bikes and build forts
and like watch watch soap operas or just
like
play run through the sprinkler like just
whatever and i was like
okay well i'm we're forming a durandran
cover band this summer and um
i'll be simon labon of course
you know and like so
and you know i would just
i would ask my dad like hey so the show
is and i was wondering if you could you
know it was before like
xerox you people you know you i'd be
like but if you could make copies at
your office like he was able to he had a
xerox machine so he would like come home
with these like flyers our cover band
was called
little d duran duran
and
we never even we never put on the show
but it just like i really loved having
that discipline for the summer where we
had and the rest of the kids her name is
yeah
they would like begrudgingly come on
because it's something to do you know
it's like okay well we'll just hang out
and um it's an activity yeah it was an
activity so i always uh and then i did
like theater in school you know kind of
a drama nerd but when i hit
like uh high school and was 15 i i
just discovered
music i mean i'd always listen to music
but i was kind of in tr like in the 80s
pop world and when i got to high school
i met these kids who are
actually listening to punk and new wave
and i i just thought oh what's this and
it was so much more um
accessible as an outlet like i was
always i you know i grew up outside
seattle
in the suburbs and i never really
thought like i'm gonna move to la and
try to make it like i just i didn't
really have that part of the
the dream down i just knew that i liked
performing and it i liked it as a way of
connecting with other people so when i
found music it just seemed so much more
immediate and it really
uh
sort of
dovetailed with my
teen angst at the right time so i just
sort of yeah took it on and started
playing that so then all the kind of
writing and performing stuff got a
little bit um
side tracked until later where so it
when people who knew me from slater
kinney were like whoa
portlandia i was like actually now i'm
kind of doing
a combination of the things i've always
wanted to do uh huh and and is that how
did you but did you i think you had said
you met fred through music more during
the slater kinney days yeah so he i had
heard of his band trench mouth uh which
was his kind of chicago like post punk
band uh
and we were in the same circles although
he really never met him during that time
i think i even stayed at his house he
was on tour
weird and i crashed at his house in
chicago with his roommate and band mate
damon so it was like i knew of the sky
and then it was suddenly like hey that
drummer from trench mouth is on saturday
night live like it was just so
weird
um i mean he had you know some
there was some stepping stepping stones
in between but in terms of like what the
world knew it was like whoa this guy's
on snl
i remember slater can you we were
playing in new york and he said uh hey
you guys should come to snl we said well
we have a show but he's like then come
afterwards you know there's a there's
always an after party so i went to that
and met him that night
uh wow yeah and you know he was
very cute he was wearing actually a
button with my face on it which
you know it could go either way i could
think this is
creepy or i could think this is
flattering it was to be fair it was a
button of me holding a koala so it's
really it's hard to make that sinister
you know it's like
yeah especially when it's on the lapel
of this very kind of
puckish like innocent
vaguely effeminate
guy this like
and he is such a music fan and i always
knew that and i think so much of his
comedic work actually is a way of him
expressing his music fandom you know
uh whether it's his like more recent
stand up you know uh comedy for drummers
it's always you know music is definitely
sort of the language that fred uses with
with comedy um so yeah i could just tell
he was
a fan and he was very uh
kind and and and we hit it off so then
we kind of started over over the next
couple years just a dialogue about
doing something collaborative and at the
beginning i assumed he wanted to do
music stuff but when he was like oh i
i'd love to try to do some sketch you
know with you or like make these little
video shorts which is what we started
out doing
um then i was like oh i'm glad we're not
doing music because i have that i you
know i have that covered and but this is
actually something that i really would
relish and i did
was that um i i'm i'm recalling one that
he did on snl later i think but there
was one that i think you guys did
together it was his one-man show sketch
you yeah so that's one of my favorites
and
and i
i saw it again recently and
i think the only difference between um
the portlandia or the version you guys
did in snl was that it was just much
longer when you guys did it everything
we did early on was so
long because there were no boundaries
like there was no parameters there was
no well in a good way yeah yeah there's
no you know network saying like well
geez this sketch is eight minutes and a
sketch should be around two yeah so we
and we would just because it was all
improvised as opposed to with portlandia
there were you know there were outlines
and then towards the end there were
scripts but this was unscripted and so
fred especially with one man's show i
mean he really did perform probably an
hour
long
one-man show that then our poor editor
and i don't remember who edited that if
it was doug loosen hop or jeff buchanan
but whoever edited that was truly
editing a completely improvised
one-man show were you in the audience
for the whole thing and i was in the
audience the whole thing so i mean
you know
well if that's a good example of like
how do you not laugh during that it's
skewers
one man shows
which we've all seen versions of uh and
it's not that
much more self-indulgent than some of
the ones i've seen i mean it's not it's
just a fraction
more i would say but it's well i mean
and that's what's so interesting i think
about real life is it's just how you
view something i mean if you go to a
one-man show
you're there with it's about intention
and also
in the ways that you receive something
you know
like what
what's your mindset in terms of re you
know receptivity so you go into a
one-man show you go in you're not going
there to laugh unless they say something
funny but you're there
for the humanity and then if you watch a
sketch about one man's show they could
literally do the same material yeah
that's true but you're allowed to laugh
that's true that's true that's why yeah
i mean i'm thinking about
the absurdity now about some of the
the performance activism that's going on
now how what you guys would do with that
um how ripe for skewering some of that
is there's so much great obviously
activism happening now i don't have to
tell you you're you're in portland
you're in the midst of it but i've also
seen just as much empty activism and you
know social media these
influencers who
post nothing but selfies and vanity
shots and then they'll be like seriously
guys you know
black lives matter this or that or you
know it's um
i miss your voices but um
i i
i can only imagine what you would do
at this time
yeah we did we did a sketch actually um
about kind of that that virtue signaling
where there was a fred and i we we were
playing the sort of carrie fred
characters which are
much more
gullible um versions of ourselves
and we were heading off the sketch is
basically exactly what you're talking
about we we were heading off to a a
rally
and um or a protest um
and
we just spent the morning letting
everyone know that we were going you
know just like because we had to stop
and get
you know we stopped at a food cart and
what are you guys doing well we're going
down to a protest you know like just
where it was very proud yeah um yeah and
yeah i think you know all of us a bit us
you know especially
those of us who
are professing like a certain kind of
allyship you know have to be careful in
terms of
like why we're doing it and sometimes
there's multiple reasons it's not like
you know there's the very earnest um
reason and then there's on top of that
that layer of um performance which i
think is hard for almost anyone to issue
right now because we're just in a
society that kind of is always
asking and also rewarding people for
you know
performance and social media is built on
you know an algorithm of of needing and
wanting likes so it's
it's hard to sort of shame people for it
but at the same time it's so it's cringy
when you feel yourself doing it and it's
it's cringy to watch other people you
know just with these empty performance
gestures
yeah cringy is that's a perfect word um
have you read i've just finished reading
talking to strangers uh i'm thinking
about your sociolinguist days and how
much you would probably love that no
what is it oh the the malcolm gladwell
book uh oh okay you're like you know
it's just malcolm gladwell you're like i
thought i'm actually i'm actually glad
it was gladwell and you weren't like
no it's one of the top you know it's in
the canon
talking to strangers you haven't heard
of it
no talking to strangers very funny i'm
sure you've read it many times uh no no
i and i i should have prefaced that by
saying i
i don't read very much uh i'm not one of
those people now i feel like
that's that's a portlandia sketch the
bookshamer um you haven't read this uh
but i just feel like you would love it
uh with yours okay i'll check it out
background um
so how
into meeting fred how you said it was
like three four years went by at what
point do you think well
we have enough material we can pitch a
show
i actually
seed credit to uh
well sort of that's like a dramatic
pause for no reason
two um
we can add some music to it
i don't know why i pause at all um i
give credit to fred's manager tim sarkis
who then became my manager uh he
just he was watching the stuff that we
were making and and we were
working under the moniker thunder ant at
the time and you know we just we put
these videos online and
you know not a ton of people saw them
um but tim just said you guys you're
developing a sensibility you guys have a
chemistry
and it feels unique and why don't you
pitch this as a show
and
we so we we made sort of a
a pilot or just kind of like a little
sizzle reel where we filmed a unique
intro and then added some of the
sketches we'd already done
and because fred was still on saturday
night live it was sort of obligatory
that he needed to run it by
lorne michaels and
andrew singer who's the head of tv at
broadway video
assuming that they would immediately be
like thank you but no like good luck
fred with your little side private weird
little side project yeah
this is too niche for us but to lauren's
credit and i think you know
he is just
very
insightful and i think is actually
always looking for something that's
interesting and and has a subversion to
it if you think of like kids in the hall
or something like that
um he was like no we we want to do this
and so
they came on um
as
eps
and then we took it out um to networks
to pitch it and what was interesting at
the time was so we pitched to
comedy central
and they said no one does sketch we
don't we're not doing sketch and then
after portlandia came around they were
like okay and then they had they had key
and peel and the schumer show within
like a year and a half but uh and that's
fine i mean that's you know that that's
no offense that's just where the trends
were that's just yeah that's that's just
how things work but um yeah at the time
there was sort it was kind of a fallow
um time for for sketch did you pitch it
to you didn't pitch it to networks
no i mean that was a
we knew it would never function there
and at the time it was
it was a little bit before
well netflix existed not quite in the
way it does now
um but we pitched to so we yeah we
didn't pitch to netflix or
um you know there was no amazon
or hulu so yeah and ifc were rebranding
at the time
um they were going to start doing more
original content and so it just kind of
worked that they were yeah taking off i
i really loved meeting that that team
i'm trying to remember who they there is
i'm terrible with names but i do
remember meeting ifc my brother and i
pitched them something we were so struck
by how
funny and open they were to
different
i would i was i always thought of ifc as
you know the independent film challenge
they just show they show gus van sant
movies and whatever um yeah it's just
quentin tarantino on on repeat yeah yeah
no i mean and you know
it was it was tricky because eventually
when when netflix came around and we
were really lucky to have portlandia air
on netflix or stream on netflix you know
that's when most people saw the show and
i'm i'm glad that it's still on netflix
because
like the rest of us you know people find
things years later you know i'm yeah
i'm watching shows that i didn't see the
first time around no i'm me i'm the guy
who like 10 years later is like have you
seen breaking bad
um
this little it's this little show
yeah and then i want to talk about it
and everyone's like yeah we talked about
it like years ago i
i don't really remember the episodes um
yeah but also like we were saying the in
terms of portlandia i think to discover
it now
is
a lot of the themes you're exploring are
so i mean you you pointed to one sketch
about uh you know they're about karen
about things that are happening right
now it's very
i think it remains relevant um
one thing that i like about portlandia i
guess is that it kind of never took
whiteness as a default it actually was a
show that really
explored i think
like it didn't take
you know the category of white people as
like well this is the norm it was like
there is some really weird [ __ ] here to
figure out like and
you know i think part of that was
because you know fred is not white and
you know and i'm coming at it as i am
white but i'm queer so you have like
these people who are like so we also
explored like heterosexuality from i was
always exploring heterosexuality as a
queer person and sort of like why you
know like it was always kind of this
dissection of like things that people
sort of prop up as like normal like
whether it's like couplehood or like
weird kind of quirkiness that like white
people perform so it it always just had
um it it just always felt like it was
kind of looking at something from the
outside as a little little little
anthropological i guess
[Music]
[Music]
what was a difference that you
recognized uh between a queer
relationship in a heterosexual
relationship that you
felt was worth exploring or mining
i think for me because again like
there's nothing essential about either
you know but there are these sort of
ways that like
maggie nelson she talks about in
argonauts like homo normativity i mean
there's all these ways that any couple
sort of veers into like convention and
then there's ways that
any couple straight gay or in between
veers into like
you know things that are unconventional
but there were just
these versions of like someone like
peter and nance like this just like
like i think as someone especially in my
20s like when i was still kind of like
grappling with my own sexuality and
really wanting to
kind of hoping i was just gonna be
straight
like i just was like really even uh into
the 20s oh yeah like i just i'm only
telling you this because it's also in my
a book i wrote so this is not like
oh my god what a big aha moment but
my dad came out in his mid-50s and it
was all of a sudden
wow i was like wait a second like this
is such a gen x like 90s
version of me because now people are so
like they'd be so excited for their
parents to be gay but i was like be cool
yeah but i was like hey hey hey like
kids are the ones that we're supposed to
like rebel against you like you need to
like hold out you need to like hold this
the family down like you have to be
traditional you gotta be traditional
like now i've got to go out and find a
husband and get married you know like it
was it was so complex like i was like oh
my god i sound so conservative like get
back in the closet dad that's so funny
but wasn't your dad also the one who
when you were you were outed of sorts by
that article in spin magazine and didn't
he say
uh carrie is there something you want to
talk to me about wasn't he a little
weird about how yeah well and he like
for sure and also i mean he wasn't like
closeted he just really didn't know
like he wasn't having any kind of secret
affairs like he just grew up at a time
where there wasn't he wasn't meeting
other
gay people he didn't really know what
these
feelings were
i mean or wasn't willing to like sort of
name them until
you know he was in the middle of his
life and also with help of the internet
and chat rooms i think you know just
just to like connect connect with other
people because i mean think of think of
the loneliness sort of you know
pre-internet for any you know buddy that
feels marginalized like just not
recognizing themselves um and not i
think oh yeah and my dad was confined to
such um straight worlds you know he he
was a corporate lawyer he lived in the
suburbs so it wasn't like he was just
surrounded by examples of like
queerness you know so there was just no
reflection
or even like not the castro yeah yeah so
there's just not even a place for him to
imagine
another version of himself until
you know the internet came around and
all of a sudden you just feel this
encroaching
like familiarity and you're like oh
there's so many other people like me
including people his own age that had
been living you know married to you know
in straight relationships terry was this
during was this after they got divorced
they got divorced when you're 14. so
was this was this while they were going
through that no no i mean after my
parents got divorced my dad dated
three women like yeah no he i mean he
was very committed to this narrative of
who he is i mean i wouldn't even call it
a narrative i mean it was his life it
was it was the script that he was
playing by and i just think it really
did he struggle in those relationships
as a result i mean did god that's
fascinating to me did he
was
did you ever talk to him about
you know what that struggle was like for
him not necessarily i mean i think
whatever that struggle was was only
obvious in the lack of struggle once he
came out you know what i mean like
because once he came out and now he's
he's married to a man and who he's been
with for over 15 years
then all of
the sort of
almost like partial
the partiality whatever like that sort
of encode version of himself i was only
recognizable in the contrast you know
like
it just seemed he didn't seem uh
repressed before and then but then when
he wasn't repressed it was like oh you
were a repressed like in so many ways
yeah just even like emotionally you know
like he just became such a fully
formed human once he came out like he
just was very closed off before and so
wow it made sense for him to not be
super affectionate with a girlfriend
because it wasn't like he was super
affectionate as a dad so it wasn't like
oh you're such a warm guy and that
you're so like frigid around your
girlfriends it was just like no he's
just this kind of uptight
you know
dude
yeah so you you saw i mean you saw an
immediate change uh in his behavior
even toward
you i mean he was just seemed more
comfort
at peace i mean yes like all of a sudden
just crying at every movie i mean sadly
it says
it was like billy elliot was just
i mean can't even for a while there was
a time where he like couldn't even talk
about billy elliot or the film big fish
or um
brian's song that story of yeah of
course gayle sayer yeah i mean suddenly
my dad it was just like water works
every time he like talked about like a
story that had to do with like a guy and
his dad and like
coming into his own and so it wasn't i
get it i'm not no i mean i'm i think
heterosexual but uh when i'm 54 because
i i also i also get emotional at all of
those movies well no and i mean to be
fair it shouldn't really be assigned to
any spectrum of sexuality it was just
that no no no
generation it's so generational too that
you know for my dad like you know he's
uh in his 70s like that just wasn't an
option to necessarily go to a movie and
come out and be like that made me really
sad it was like it was just he's just
had access
to so much more of himself and i think i
think a lot of i think a lot of people
now have hopefully have access to all
those parts of themselves from an early
age but i think generationally for him
that just did not exist
yeah for sure my dad i mean my dad is
the
man my dad's not the same in that he is
he's repressing some sexuality but he um
i think the older he's gotten and the
more
uh in touch with our
emotions we've been and we should we
show them that him that it's okay i
think he's now
uh more at peace with you know
expressing those emotions and and being
connected to
yeah i mean it must be such a relief to
just sort of be given permission you
know cultural permission or or even like
on a smaller smaller level just familial
permission to just not have to hold all
that stuff in you know to not have to
signify
maleness like as as
these systems just start to erode and
you know they're sort of they're sort of
late you know long overdue and being
like deconstructed
i think
it's actually very um liberating for a
lot of people because it also takes a
lot to hold up those systems and i think
you know for
certain like cis white men like not
everyone is just like uh like
let me re-examine this and by
re-examining this i'm actually i'm also
a better person you know
absolutely and it's interesting that you
had that reaction to your dad because i
would think
uh
of of all people you know you you were
saying you struggled with this in your
20s and
it was something that you were not at
peace with for a while and it's so
interesting that your reaction wasn't
like oh dad all right you know that it
was like wait what the [ __ ] i like it as
an example because it is so deeply
contradictory and i just think this idea
of holding two truths at once is so
important for understanding like the
flawed nature
of people you know and the and the parts
that just don't line up and i think you
know we all struggle with accepting that
in ourselves and also accepting that in
other people that they can be both
things that they can have done really
great things and then
like also done something that we
disagree with like it's just you know
that's where a lot of
that's where humanity comes from and
that's where so much art comes from you
know are those those places of
discomfort those those little like
problem areas that we just can't like
iron out you know that's that's where
the novel springs from or that's where
the song
springs from are all those thorny parts
so as much as i sort of hate to admit
that i was like what
when my dad came out it's just like
that's but that's just between that can
be so contradictory that i could like be
queer myself that i could
believe so fundamentally in like
you know human rights and equality and
all these things and then but want my
dad just to be
a straight dad that you know and then my
dad embodies these amazing
contradictions too where you know again
he's out and proud and married to a man
and um lives in a a small town in in
washington state that is very
conservative and
has like stood out as an example like he
and his husband you know have probably
changed minds we know one
neighbor at a time but he occasionally
will just say the most homophobic [ __ ]
you know i'll just like i i moved into
this house um
in la and the the couple that lived
there before me it was two men and my
dad and his husband were at my house and
um he was asking about the previous
owners and you know i i said it was this
couple two guys and he's like oh the
mirrored ceilings in there and i was
like what are you talking about
you jerk like
first of all
like
i was like it's i mean it really could
have
like anyway i i it was so offensive and
funny but i was also like you got rid of
all the chandeliers yeah i loved it i
was like dad liberace did not own this
house like these were just two guys like
and but i have to say i love i kind of
love it because people just are
really complex and
i was like dad how dare you but also
that's so you you're like a mid a guy in
your mid 70s making some assumptions
yeah yeah i love that well that that is
very scary that's very monty python
that's very like um
making fun of this thing that you
yourself are participating in um
uh what is your most commonly used emoji
would you say
oh i use the one where it's just the
the flat
it's like no expression do you know what
i'm talking about but with a mouth it
has a mouth and it's just going flat
across
oh nice uh okay
and you punctuate uh anything with that
not anything but yeah um i think that's
yeah i'm in love with you yeah i like to
use it in lieu of an exclamation point
yes
um if you could be a professional
athlete what sport would you play
basketball
oh you follow basketball yes you like it
yeah who's your team the portland
trailblazers trailblazers that makes
sense um oh hey speaking of uh portland
do you know honey mama's the company
honey mamas it's a portland mom and pop
no sorry there's some
okay i should check it out check them
out okay yeah made with are you a vegan
vegetarian no
okay you'll like them though uh okay uh
if you could have one snack food
speaking of honey mamas for the rest of
your life what would it be
um cashews
oh no that's like such a boring i mean
what
also chips also chips and salsa
okay i mean not yeah you love cashews
that much i don't it's this is like
lightning round means you're getting
answers that are not right you're right
okay i mean you got to accept these what
do you think okay yes you're right um uh
what's your favorite movie of all time
oh boy oh boy
this is a yeah that's a tough lightning
one that's a really tough lightning how
about this carry what in quarantine have
you found uh yourself watching that
brings you kind of comfort okay well
actually one one movie that i do love
that is probably one of my favorite
movies is the last picture show
oh
yeah i love that one i was just watching
easy riders and raging bulls the
documentary they were i it makes me now
want to re-watch last picture show it's
a talk about it it's a great show great
movie um great great tv show such a
great tv show
it's on quib it's on quibby it's like
through little bite size
um the latest picture show uh if you
have to live somewhere else where would
it be
um
france
okay
uh if you could have dinner with three
people dead or alive whom you've never
met
okay uh dorothy parker
james baldwin
um
gosh who would the last person be
maybe
eddie van halen oh and that that would
be that would be a wild um i would you
know what i'll throw robert plant i'll
actually throw robert plant in there so
i'll do robert plant dorothy parker
and james baldwin wow that's a hell of a
dinner but by the way do you remember
when robert plant was living with patty
griffin yes
and that's partly why i thought of him
because i mean he's the only living one
out of the two i mentioned the other two
but he is so he has great stories i mean
all three of those people would have
great stories
but you know i uh you know
i think i think a musician would be a a
good third person there
just from oh god life i know that well
that was so crazy when he was just
living in austin like and just
down for me
around i know that's wild justin yeah i
mean i just remember going over
now this is just such a humble brag from
both of us like a joint humble brag
if there's a way to combine the term
circle jerk and humble brag
a circle
so this circle brag that we're doing
is about both of us having met robert
plant and knowing that he's just a great
storyteller such a kind human and just
completely in a great way
kind of
destroying every idea you know you think
of zeppelin like just oh with all the
grand edenism and like he must be an
[ __ ] and he's the opposite and he's
so he just thinks of about art all the
time and pushing himself forward as a
singer-songwriter yeah i was pretty cool
ugh another one of many reasons i'm so
indebted to liz lambert the great liz
lambert
and that album oh well whatever so much
to talk about okay sorry uh well who's
your favorite muppet
oh um
probably gonzo
oh yeah oh you and i talked to joel
mchale yesterday who was also from your
uh from outside of seattle and he said
gonzo too gonzo too yeah we were
required if you grew up
yes
okay
yeah wish i had known that i wouldn't
have asked
um
if you could be one age for the rest of
your life physically uh what would you
pick knowing what you know now having
your experiences i would say probably
37.
ah okay that was a good one uh if you
could be uh would you rather people call
you unattractive or unfunny oh
unattractive for sure
uh-huh um
which i'm not saying they would uh but
here here's let me just set it up for
all the trolls out there
well she's both well too bad because
you're
both i like i like beating the trolls to
the punch yeah
um
yeah would you uh i hate trolls which
which golden girl
the idea of anybody trolling you i i
have such a i hold you in such esteem
and like i just think you're such a
trolls are universal trolls are like the
common it's the great equalizer we each
have a troll we each have a little troll
traveling around with us
and in us yeah and in us
yeah um
which golden girl do you most identify
with dorothy blanche rose or sophia
sophia
oh yeah okay uh
okay uh dogs are cats dogs
yeah um and the beetles are the rolling
stones
oh this is a real tough one you know
what that real
[ __ ] in me will just be like the
kinks
cool answer yeah um
yeah i do i do love the kinks and i was
just listening to a great uh i was
listening to your to slater kinney and
on spotify
uh a cover of lola came on
and i thought oh [ __ ] is this did you
guys do this no what's it been was it
the uh raincoats
yes okay cool uh no but really i i mean
i probably would say the beatles
yeah um
i i know you gotta go i i could do this
for another hour and a half
one thing is it's going to be a hundred
here today so i i just have to get
cricket who is my dog out before it is a
hundred of course
okay
because if she perishes out there in the
heat
you will be getting a phone call oh my
god i feel so
we'll be doing a follow-up we'll be
doing a follow-up podcast
oh my god
uh no and i uh yeah i mean if you don't
follow carrie on instagram uh
you should and then you'll be familiar
with cricket is just the
and my apologies i am just i have taken
a long social media break this summer
mostly
so so i can focus on what's in front of
me which is
um
my city which is going through a lot uh
my friends
and uh and just my mental health but
well apology not accepted i mean but
sure follow me and eventually i'll post
something um but speaking of carrie uh
sorry really quick what is a good um
what can people follow in terms of what
is happening in portland uh any friends
of yours who are um well there's some
great organizations uh don't shoot pdx
is
a great uh organization to follow um
p-o-i-c-r-a-h-s
which is a long acronym
but uh they're another great
organization
okay so one is a great um instagram to
follow is pdx blm events
and so every day they post like if you
know you want to get involved today
here's where people are just doing sign
waving here's
where there's uh an actual
march or rally or protest
here we're meeting up for you know
a mental health check-in like there's
just so many different events they um
kind of bring together all of them
uh care not cops pdx is great too but um
yeah don't shoot pdx is a long-standing
uh organization here
and they've been on the front lines for
years and years and i think
they're if i was going to recommend one
place i would check them out
don't shoot pdx pdx blm events and um
and of course carrie to see cricket
updates yes
uh eventually
um well
my apologies to cricket and uh
and cricket's bladder
she's fine she has been let out to the
bathroom okay okay she just we just
we're just gonna go we have to exercise
we have to exercise uh yeah oh 100
degrees no she's not just she's not just
down like with her leg downstairs with
her legs crossed like
holding it in
no she's fine
you clearly you clearly understand how
animals work
oh yeah my god i i haven't had one in
way too long though um it's really good
to see you
you too
it is um if i do make that trip uh if i
do that that rv trip i will let you know
if i'm in the area and
we'll hang out we can we can go on like
a socially distanced walk or something i
would love that okay okay take care
well that happened well that has so that
happened so that happened i don't know
which one is it it happened so that just
happened the important part is uh saying
it happened so that just happened hmm
that happened
carrie studied socio
oh very cool cool is that i didn't know
that i wish my college had offered that
well and who is it so someone in in a
letter said you would excel at that they
think i'm not saying i would but it just
sounds like
yeah yeah i would be interested in it
for sure
it really it makes sense when you
consider
what they did on portland a lot of that
was exploring the absurdity of human
behavior through language yes with such
nuance too and you mentioned that to her
by the way why don't you tell her you
like porlandia
shut up
there was a split my brain is slower now
that i'm older i can feel like
information traveling up and it was like
for a very split second i was like what
my friend was like down now he's joking
but that satire is so good and so
effective i think because
it is so subtle some of those points are
so true to life i know like the way they
skewer certain types of people or
situations it's so brilliant because
it's just slightly
heightened and sometimes don't you meet
people especially actors i mean we meet
people in like showbiz who
are themselves heightened um and and
they feel like portlandia characters i
mean i've heard people in
i'm thinking like austin or silver lake
or like kind of trendy hip liberal areas
where
they go on about um the ethically
sourced food that they're eating you
know and they come just short of that
sketch where kamal is taking their order
and describing where the chicken's from
and what the chicken's name is like that
is a brilliant sketch because it is so
close to how people behave and i think
portland happens to be yeah i haven't
spent that much time there but it
happens to be kind of the extreme yeah
version of a lot of these people that do
exist throughout the country i think
it's it's concentrated in portland but
you see that everywhere oh yeah
in austin certainly you see it in new
york yeah but when portlandia started it
was mostly a portland thing austin there
were a few pockets of that kind of like
like ultra hipster ultra brooklyn was
becoming like that but i think now
you're right i think now like you see it
in indianapolis i'm sure there's an
enclave like that in orlando i've seen
it
i've seen it in tucson like
yeah that's i used to see that
everywhere now
and i haven't spent much time in
portland have you only been there for
the show um
i think so and i loved it i was there
for two nights once and i remember being
so impressed by the food and the
cleanliness
it was so
i didn't see one piece of litter and i
walked all around the city i did so much
walking i didn't see
one cigarette butt a one
rapper of anything you know incredible
you know what i think part of that is
and i was talking about this yesterday
with a future guest pete holmes i can
mention it i know you're gonna shame me
but uh well he's not a future guest
because you have an interview oh right
i'm going to be on his show
sorry um but i was talking about how
much it frustrates me to what extent it
frustrates me when i see people
littering and how i take that as like
almost like a personal front like
they're gonna just how disrespectful it
is i am so offended by that oh god it
infuriates me and i i i want to like
take it and i get angry i want to shove
it in their face and um it's so
disrespectful it is i was at marshall's
a few weeks ago and i saw this marshall
louise
and i saw this um this person get back
in their car
and they had bought so many pieces of
clothing they just so casually took the
tags off
and sprinkled them out of their car
window of their parked car i was so
engaged but what do you do what do you
do well didn't call the cops didn't
maggie want to shame that like i wasn't
even gonna include that part of the
story i'm sorry but yeah she like walked
up and just stared at her and i was like
get back in the car you're gonna like
cause a scene yeah maggie maggie's like
one like max our dog max like maggie's
like one of those little dogs that
doesn't know its size and is like
like goes after the big dogs um
will she be flattered by that or
insulted it's hard to say yeah well
we'll see i don't think she'll be
insulted yeah because it's so true and
also she's dog and she loves dogs and
she's small she's like talks
and she knows that she does it so yeah i
don't see why she would be um yeah i
hate it so much but
getting back to portland um i i wonder
if that's has something to do with my
love of portland which is like
i i i feel like the people there are
there's a respect that they have for
their
city for their for the sidewalks you
know even right that you don't see it
because that's a communal that takes a
communal that's a communal effort to
keep a city like that that clean i think
i'm sure they have good sanitation
department all that but small things can
be so incredibly revealing about about a
person yeah and it seems little like
um not waiting your turn at a four-way
stop
that doesn't not waiting your turn
doesn't make you a terrible person or
anything but
it's indicative of a very selfish
mentality of like i need to get
somewhere yeah and where i have to go is
more important than where you have to go
and it's it's very simple but it's it's
revealing about a person yeah same with
littering it's the same mentality it's
also
um cutting somebody off
uh
cutting somebody off uh or not moving if
you're in the fast lane you're going 40
miles an hour on the highway or if you
make a mistake how about this one this
one kills me you make a mistake somebody
cuts you off whatever and they don't
wave or you let somebody in there's no
wave you don't get the waves speaking of
cutting off
i found it very
impressive
that she
would never cut you off in the
conversation yeah she has this and it's
part of what makes her
smart and confident but cool
and respectful she's a good listener
good listener that she wouldn't jump in
and she would kind of wait for you to be
done making a point and then she would
talk and
it's um it's respectful but it also
demands that the person she's talking to
makes a point well like has a point that
has a beginning middle and end and mine
often don't have ends
i get frustrated well in the beginning
they flustered but i felt like you
you warmed into that conversation here's
why i knew you were gonna notice that
because well because it's noticeable uh
but also i am so um
i admire her so much i think i i think
her intellect her intellect and i so i
think there's a part of me that is
intimidated by that intellect it's also
the way we grew up we grew up
i mean not to blame everything on our
parents but our that was a that was
something to be valued in our house was
like in an intellect and it's a good
blame yeah yeah yeah that's true i think
that's part of it i i would get because
she was waiting for a point and um
i i got nervous you wanted to get to the
but like i'm doing now right
and i noticed sometimes when she would
um try to make a point she would stop
herself and be like i'm going to start
that again yes and go back to the
beginning yes because she really values
the way she puts her points together yes
yeah
she values language yes sociology is one
of the reasons that show is so good
exactly yeah well i think we just
figured her out
cracked the impressive code i liked how
during the um
the lighting round
you asked what her favorite snack was
and she's like cashews and you're like
really cashews and she's like no not
really but it's a lightning round so i
felt like i had to say something quickly
well she was literal i mean she was like
yeah respond it's how it's also a gut
thing it should be we've talked about
cashews is also something that even
though it's maybe not the most delicious
snacks who said cashews it's a good one
to pick yeah because it's reasonably
healthy people said almonds yeah you
know we were talking about how much we
love portland so i i just want to send
our our best wishes because they're
going through uh they're going through
it yeah and it's you know when that
happened i i know i shouldn't be you
don't want to be prejudiced
you know when i put one city above
another you know there were all people
in this together but uh there was
something about hearing what was going
on in portland that that hit me a little
bit harder than
because they're so
respectful and yeah they're yeah
community oriented and they don't litter
they don't let her i value i know that
don't let her both aftermath you said he
said don't let her uh let's read a
letter okay
a litter
um okay
uh this is from ella you know that means
in spanish
she
does duolingo
not an ad oh that's christian hates the
sound that it makes
if anyone's ever heard the duolingo app
you'll know how annoying that sound is
or
or satisfying if you're doing the
duolingo app and not just overhearing it
sure okay subject some back to ella
ella ella oh she must be sick of that oh
yeah then what a great song though when
the sun shines it shines together ding
ding dong dilling you sound just like
rihanna how did you do that
uh i studied her ding ding ding dong
hello ella
hey okay
subject please cut that out me
please don't cut that out
overruled
you're the producer
uh some for loco
slash condiment would you rather it's
great and hold some grandpa content
great
hi justin and christian i hope this
finds you well smiley face my name is
ella i'm 25 and from westchester new
york oh i don't know
yeah i dated a lady from westchester
who's that from rye oh
was she rye
sometimes um i dated a lady from
westchester too wow you don't bother me
ladies from rochester
i've been back to ella i've been an avid
listener of the pod since it started a
year ago the grandma jody episode is my
absolute favorite oh hope she's doing
well and got some new hearing aids she
hasn't
she hasn't she had it worked on she had
it like she took it into the shop
to have it and um
we haven't gotten her one i mean it's my
it's our fault but she won't let us she
want i keep asking her what brand what
um for her doctor's information she
won't you just saw her the other day i
saw her the other day she's doing very
well she is but her hearing aid is still
making that like i could hear it it's
like it's making a um
sounds a little bit like a spacecraft
and
close encounters or a mosquito a little
bit like a mosquito but like a
digitalized mosquito oh
and she can't hear anything and she's
and everything else about her seems so
healthy like she's so present she's
still she hasn't really like missed a
step it's crazy
i introduced her i was growing up i was
given a cannabis plant and um it was a
funny video i post check it out on my
instagram back to the letter anyways i
just want to thank you both for the work
you're doing and for putting out such
wonderful and engaging content god
that's nice
thanks ella i love listening to the pod
while i'm water coloring or doing other
doodling how cool
yeah justin doodles i do i do doodle i
doodle uh it brings me so much joy and
is such a fun and anxiety relieving
distraction during these weird scary
times i'm writing to you for a couple of
reasons first i have two would you
rather questions for you great and i
would love to hear your answers awesome
thanks ella okay number one would you
rather never be able to put any
condiments on sandwiches for the rest of
your life i'd love that or
have to eat eight tablespoons of plain
warm mayo every morning for the next
four years
note knowing justin and christian from
listening to the podcast i understand
this may lead into a bigger conversation
of what defines a condiment ah i will
leave that up to you both to decide wait
hold on remind me so the first one is um
for the rest of your life no condiments
never be able to put any condiments on
sandwiches for the rest of your life now
do you think that extends to wraps as
well
yes okay i think
that's a sandwich okay
or
i'm in the earl of sandwich might
disagree
isn't it funny that he probably did all
these like remarkable things or not
maybe he was like a lazy rich guy and
just like give me i i i'm holding my
this my scepter in my other hand and i
see i think that the earl of sandwich
has um remains popular just because he
has a funny name
like general so you know because general
so is delicious chicken no general
well that's what that's what i'm saying
like general so did
a lot of [ __ ] i mean he was a general so
what
all right let's get back to the would
you rather um no condiments and
sandwiches or four years of eight
tablespoons of mayo every morning
you get used to it though i bet the mayo
yeah i'm sure but i don't hate mayo
i think condiments some sandwiches are
somewhat overrated so i would definitely
wait uh those condiments i know ella
left this up to us but uh what about
burgers
let's include that in sandwiches okay um
let's say sandwiches or anything that
has uh
equal tops and bottoms and a filling in
the middle so that's grinders that's
burgers grinders
[Laughter]
um
oh i would i i'm
i'm not a huge condiment person no
tahini
see even burgers i like ketchup on
burgers for instance but i i also like
burgers without ketchup you know i'm not
a huge condiment people i'm not a big
condom person and i also don't hate mayo
but the thought of having to do
it's also really unhealthy to have eight
tablespoons of mayo also it'd also be a
gross way to start their day eight years
four years you're right and and what if
you only lived another four and a half
years you know then it's like oh [ __ ] i
should have taken that um i would
definitely lose the condiments
because if you have good ingredients in
a sandwich true you don't need
condiments condiments are to cover up
uh kind of mediocre you know what you
would you know what you would miss is
that uh thanksgiving that turkey
sandwich at the firehouse deli you
wouldn't get cranberry sauce fine yeah
but it's been a year i know i've had
that and you know another nice thing
about taking the condiments one is that
it would it might encourage you to eat
less sandwiches i don't think sandwiches
are all that fewer sandwiches but i
would also say um i would also say that
[ __ ] you're right that thanksgiving
sandwich that is comprised of turkey
stuffing and cranberry sauce
i don't know if cranberry sauce would be
considered a condiment yep i don't think
so that's it's it's its own thing it's
its own ingredient it's not wiped on
like mustard
i mean what's a condiment exactly i i
think it's it has the similar texture to
other condiments so anything like relish
anything wet is a condiment um
yeah i think so
i think so any sort like think about
that what is that like oh juice that's
put on some of those
what's you
what sandwich does that put on like a
beef uh like a dip like a french dip
beef beef is a gross word okay all right
uh yeah i would choose the condiment one
um
uh getting rid of the condiments yeah
exactly me too um number two but gray
one ella number two would you rather
drink 48 ounces of milk flavored for
loco
or for local flavored milk okay so 48
ounces of either
milk flavored for loco
or for logo flavored milk uh i would i
would do the milk milk yeah yeah i have
every day or just once 48 ounces
i can't drink that four loko well four
loco also i don't really know if
they each have a different flavor so i
don't know what um
a four loko flavor is exactly
it's like wacky uh wild berry it's like
yeah so but just in terms of
so the flavor i don't know really like a
creamy texture is that what it would be
maybe a for local flavored milk
but i would choose the milk i mean both
would be disgusting but i would choose
the milk that tasted like four loco yeah
probably just healthier too healthier
and also um
the alcohol of four loco i i haven't had
four loko in about 10 years but i
remember
um it's so potent this stuff that i
remember once i had one and they're tall
cans and they're so loaded with sugar
and alcohol
i had one of them and i went from
sober to wasted in like seven minutes
it was the crazy experience i know
weren't we celebrating something we were
uh like selling a case of yours yeah
yeah we're like let's crack open a four
loko and sell that stuff is so dangerous
so imagine having 48 ounces i feel like
i'd be in the hospital so i would
definitely pick the milk 48 yeah and um
although i have not been drinking milk
it's been really nice uh who cares
second something that's been making me
so happy recently has been talking to my
grandpa joe ah good name i know you and
your listeners don't know him but since
quarantine started he's been writing his
life story on facebook that's so cool he
just discovered facebook and is truly
thriving anyways i've included a video
of him oh i wish we could see it i'm
reading this off a piece of paper so
obviously we'll be able to look it up
and see it though yeah she attached it
and that i beg of you to watch despite
not knowing him i feel very strongly
that you will find this grandpa j
content uplifting and hilarious and i
hope it brings a smile to your face i i
want to see it in the video he's
reminiscing about a story from his
childhood growing up in little
that's hard for me to say little italy
little italy the street he lived on was
actually named renamed
moscow street wow our last name to honor
his father my great grandpa wow cool
not only is he the best storyteller i
know but he is truly and i don't use
this word lightly or ever iconic as the
kids say
do you know the kids also say facts have
you heard of that you just told me about
that oh yeah so when something's right
my friend just told me about that
because uh it's like oh true
facts
have you heard that no but i i don't
hate that no no facts i don't like i
don't even overuse iconic but i do
believe ella when she says her
grandfather i do too i like ellen okay
all right uh and then back to ella all
right well not sure if you made it to
the end but if you did wow i really i
really appreciate it give me some credit
ella uh sending lots of love and
gratitude to you both thanks so much for
what you do that's one of the best
letters all the best ella all the best
back ella that's so cool i can't wait to
check out grandpa joe
the story is called louis the butcher
story i want to hear that uh it's
amazing they named the street after him
i want to check out that street too and
literally check out the uh i missed the
video after okay because it's not it
doesn't make for great podcasts no no no
just me talking about wanting to see a
video i know
okay uh thanks ella and thank you uh
ella's cool as is our was our guest
today is our guest carrie
ella seems like she has some carrie
brownstein um cool energy i agree and
what a compliment maybe the highest uh
oh and thanks to carrie
you know we talk about it on the show a
lot our movie
lady of the manor which we're very
excited for everyone to see oh you
singing that song tour in the beginning
oh is it weird no it was fun
how would you sing the song
i wouldn't do it yeah i wouldn't i
wouldn't try i forgot the name of it i
know yeah i know it so well as and she
knew right away what i was talking i
mean not that because the rendition was
so good because she had been
you know privy to us trying to get this
song in our movie anyway so if you guys
want to write in yeah our email address
is life is short at wondery.com
and we love letters and would you
rathers
yes and preferably both in one letter
like but not necessary yeah they don't
all have to be as good as ella's letter
no it's a high bar uh so thanks to
everyone listening and uh to the the
cool ella and carrie thank you guys uh
and we'll we'll
be
talking to you next week
i haven't eaten see you next week
life is short is hosted by me justin
long it is co-hosted and produced by you
christian long and megan monaco senior
producer is michelle miesh lance uh
audio engineer is sergio enriquez with
executive producers executive producers
are you want to stay with executive
producers it would change the the people
would be so thrown by it
uh as well as executive producers
marshall louis and hernan lopez for a
company called does that bother you not
so much okay
wondering wondering okay have a good
week
it is somewhat growing on me
yeah
i don't i don't like it but when i first
saw it i was repulsed by it and now i
don't find a repulsor yes
yes that's weird
you know
it's like an arrow flame i mean yeah
well yeah if you had
an arrow flynn
face or demeanor i mean it's a good
thing you have a narrow plan do i have
more of an aeroflown face or demeanor
face which because he was a maniac he
was like a drunken
sex addict
i mean you're like you don't know you
you don't want a narrow flame demeanor i
don't think but how about this an arrow
flynn persona on screen like a
swashbuckler yeah or his face which one
is more similar yeah um
you